the Joe Rogan experience when you think
of human evolution do you ever stop to
think what are we going to be like a
million years from now if we do survive
what have you ever done this sort of
thought experiment we say okay if things
keep going the same way right we used to
be very strong and very hairy and we're
getting you know progressively softer as
we don't need to use our bodies as much
our brains are getting larger our heads
are getting bigger do you you do that
sort of thought experiment to see what
we're gonna be common not in a
systematic scientific way because the
process is so fraught with incredible
detail that I think it's hard for
anybody even experts in evolutionary
biology to really tell us anything that
will hold water that's really predictive
but on a general level yeah I mean
because I you know people often wonder
why is it that we haven't been visited
by aliens right this is the thing that
comes up whenever you're talking about
other life inside the universe yeah yeah
yeah but but the answer to that could be
quite straightforward nobody out there
cares about us because we're so ill
developed we're so young on the cosmic
scene that there's nothing interesting
for them to find here on planet earth so
to me there's a natural explanation for
why there can be stuff out of there life
out there and yet they don't hang out
around planet Earth it's just we don't
hang around an anthill to try to have a
conversation with you know what's going
on inside that particular structure i
buy that argument the least you do is
we're interested in butterflies
butterflies are so boring
where we're interested in moles we're
we're interested in interested in in
twirls we're interested in them for very
specific reasons all right so typically
we're interested either because we want
to see the evolutionary development that
yields this particular life-form or
because there's a general curiosity
about how this object is put together if
these other beings are so far beyond us
that those kinds of taxon and taxonomy
questions are no longer of any interest
then hanging around here may not hold
anything for them to make the journey
and stick around long enough for us to
notice I don't buy that again for two
reasons
why would we assume that they're so far
beyond us that they wouldn't be
interested in these talking monkeys with
thermonuclear weapons who dominate an
entire planet yeah that would be
fascinating ripen on some planet right
somewhere where people are the
politicians all lie to themselves
everyone gets video through the sky if
they fly in metal tubes that hurl over
the stove over the oceans right it
pollute the oceans and eat all the fish
like these people are [ __ ] crazy
yeah we've got to go there and check
this out but but imagine that this
civilization the notion of lording over
a planet is like us talking about you
know the ant lording over a grain of
sand so they may be galactic as opposed
to planetary in their hegemony and the
notion of some little tiny rock orbiting
some nondescript star in the suburbs of
this completely ordinary galaxy off
there on the side may not have the kind
of pole that you imagine that it does
how I disagree we think it's interesting
when we see a chimp use a rock to open
up a nut you know we think it's
interesting that you know there's
there's a an amazing photograph of an
orangutan that's spearfishing have you
ever seen it I have seen that actually
yeah yeah right no it is he learned it
from people apparently but it still
interesting nonetheless right but I
don't think a hundred years from now
we're gonna be as interested in these
kind of qualities or a thousand years
from now or ten thousand years from well
so we assumed that these things that
come here from another planet are more
than ten thousand years
well that's because that's that's a very
good question and I think the answer to
that is we look at the history of the
cosmos until today and it's say let's
just call it our universe to be concrete
13.8 billion years and we look at life
on planet Earth and it's you know a
handful of billions of years old so in a
handful of billions of years you can go
from some complex molecules to human
beings let's say you say it like it's
not that long it was it was it's not
that long because you know imagine that
life began a few billion years earlier
in some other system you know stars and
galaxies they were starting up you know
a billion years after the Big Bang so it
could be that life in other
world's has a head start on us by a few
billion years and we know what can
happen in a few billion years it can
days from single cell to us and you can
imagine from a few billion years from
now into the future it could be
radically different so to say it's ten
thousand years ahead of us that to me
would be the unexplained coincidence how
unlikely that they start and we started
with them ten thousand years in the span
of billions of years that seems unlikely
it isn't it doesn't seem unlikely when
you're talking about the infinite size
of the universe and this perhaps an
infinite number of Brian green showed up
there talking to an infinite numbers of
me good point good point so you're
absolutely right we're almost guaranteed
if the spatial expanse of the universe
is implements that there are going to be
places where it's within ten thousand
years or more but those are going to be
a very small number compared to the
places where it's not ten thousand is
that true or would it be an infinite
number of them well it is but there are
different kinds of infinity so you mean
you know in this space the exact scope
of the universe itself a small number
relatively speaking to where we are well
I would say slightly differently I'd say
look at a finite size ball in this large
space okay so everything's finite let's
get a five billion light year all right
and within that ball the number that are
differing from us by ten thousand years
would be very very small compared to the
number differing from us by say a
billion years or a couple of billion
years so there's simply by the law of
numbers if we imagine that they're
random processes that are general now
there could be some physical principle
that prevents life from emerging before
say four billion years ago hmm and if
that's the case and we're not aware of
that principle then you'd be absolutely
right
that we'd all be roughly at the same
starting point and there's no reason to
suspect that they would be so far ahead
of us but I don't know of any such
principle but yeah yeah you almost have
a reductionist view of this right like
you did you so if you had a guess if you
had a hundred dollars to bet has alien
life ever observed us you would say no
well by observed you mean could they
just turn a big telescope in our
direction and gather some radio waves
you know
but but yes I would take that bet
because frankly we have only been
generating radio waves for the last you
know 70 years so it's only a 70 light
year ball around us and within that
small radius very unlikely that there's
been some alien world that's examining
us so it would have to be something that
would be able to recognize our signal
and visit us right but don't we look at
observable planets and solar systems and
discover Goldilocks planets we didn't we
examine those planets from vast
distances away yes and wouldn't you
assume that a life-form that is perhaps
thousands of years more advanced than us
with the exponential increase in yes
knowledge II mean if they ever got to
the point where we are that they would
see these Goldilocks planets as well and
recognize that Earth is one of them yes
however if they are so far away they're
going to be examining earth as it was
hundreds of thousands or millions or
billions of years ago right so if you
truly want them to be examining us in
the sense of human presence on planet
Earth then it's a much more difficult
proposition to imagine that they've
actually been doing is it possible
there's another way to examine things
where you're not hampered by the speed
of light oh not not not on that I know
of I mean any signal in the world that
we're aware of is restricted by a very
by the speed of travel which is now look
there's quantum entanglement which is a
strange property of the quantum world in
which distant objects can behave as if
they are one yes and in some sense
respond instantaneously to an influence
in one location at a distant location no
matter how far apart they are but that
isn't really observing that more that's
more realizing correlations between
physical properties that
widely-separated locations but I'm not
aware of a means of leveraging that to
actually observe what's happening in
some distant location even if you do
have quantum entangled particles
[Applause]